The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK,
thank you for coming today.
The day before Thanksgiving.
Day before my
birthday, actually.
So it's a special day.
Everybody gets an
A for showing up.
Even you.
So, let's see.
Last time, I wrote down these
formulas for the Fourier
integral transform.
And I thought I'd
just write them again
so you kind of photograph
them and remember them.
They're easy to remember.
As always, you
take the function,
you multiply by e^(-ikx),
and you integrate.
To get the amount-- So k
is my frequency variable.
It could well have been
omega or some other variable.
I stayed with k because it
was k in the Fourier series.
So that's the calculation
which as always, I mean,
these are integrals
that we may be
able to do if the function is
especially nice, or we may not.
But that's the formula.
And then to reconstruct
the function,
we combine all they e^(ikx)'s
in that amount to get f(x) back.
OK, nice formula.
So I did one example last
time, and now could I just
double it up?
This is also in
the textbook and so
this is now going to
be an even function.
Last time the example I
did was zero up to x=0.
This time I'll
make it symmetric,
make the function even.
And then I have two
pieces in the integral.
And if you remember
what it was, you
remember that this, I'll
just remind you what we did.
We wrote that it's e^(-(a+ik)x).
That was clear.
And then when we integrated we
got that same function divided
by -(a+ik).
And then we put in the limits.
And the answer was, let me maybe
write the answer down here.
Was just at x equal
infinity the limit
was zero because this
thing is tailing off.
At x=0 this is one.
It comes in with a minus
because that's the lower limit.
So it was 1/(a+ik)
for the first half.
And we were not
surprised to see this 1/k
because the first
half all by itself
has that jump, from zero to one.
So we see that jump
reflected in slow decay.
Alright, but now
I'm making it even.
What are you going to guess for
the rate of decay of f hat of k
for this function?
This function no
longer has a jump.
But it does have - I don't know
were we saying ramp, or corner?
This is not a smooth point here,
because the derivative going up
is plus a, so I'll just
put a circle right,
the derivative is a*e^(ax),
and at x=0 that would be plus
a going up.
And here the derivative
is -a*e^(-ax).
Put in x=0, and the derivative
coming down is minus x.
So there's a jump
in the derivative.
So what, just before
we see it, what
will you expect for the rate
of decay of the transform?
One over k to what power, now?
So it didn't have a
jump, a jump was 1/k.
This has a jump
in the derivative,
so we're expecting one
over k squared. k squared,
it'll be one order smoother.
OK, you can easily
see that happen.
Because this part, well
this is just e^((a-ik)x),
which I'm going to integrate
to get this thing over a-ik.
And I'm going to plug in the
limits minus infinity and zero.
And at minus infinity
I'll get nothing,
this e^(ax) at minus
infinity will be zero.
Where the function starts.
Way down at zero.
So and at x=0, this is a one.
So I just get 1/(a+ik).
Over a minus, thank you.
Right, over a minus.
And somehow it
can't be an accident
that this is the complex
conjugate of that somehow.
That's not a surprise.
OK, so let's put those
together into a single fraction
and see what we have.
So the denominator
of that fraction
will be this times this.
And that's the most
basic multiplication
of complex numbers.
That one times its
conjugate gives me what?
It gives me an a squared.
And what else?
A plus k squared
because i times minus i
is plus k squared,
and no imaginary part.
There's a plus i k
a and a minus i k a,
all we're seeing here
is the sum of squares.
The usual z times z bar.
And in the numerator, let's see.
When I put it over
this-- So this
was putting it over
this common denominator,
so I should have an a-ik
going up on top there.
And an a+ik going
up on top here.
Right?
Those are my two fractions.
That over this,
and that over this.
And now that numerator
simplifies, oh look it's great.
I'm getting a real answer.
And because the minus
ik and the plus ik
cancel, and it's just the 2a.
And probably no
surprise that somehow
that that's the jump in slope.
That must have something
to do with that 2a.
So we got a real even, Fourier--
f hat from my real even f.
And it decays like k squared.
OK, so that's
another good example.
A very useful example.
Right.
I could add other examples.
One quite, before I use
that in application,
let's do just a
few more examples.
Suppose f(x) is
the delta function.
What's f hat of k?
Can you just plug in
f(x)=delta(x) here?
Do that integration, and what
does f hat of k come out to be?
One.
Because if it's a delta
function there, at x,
at x=0 the spike is at x=0,
so I plug in x=0, I get one.
So we're kind of,
we'd be surprised
if it wasn't a constant, right?
A delta function
in physical space
goes in-- has all
frequencies in equal amounts.
And it's a constant
in frequency space.
Then there's one more that
takes a little trick to do,
but it's a very neat one.
f(x) is e to the minus
x squared over two.
Do you recognize that as
an important function,
e to the minus x
squared or it usually
has that e to the minus
x squared over two
or sometimes an e to the
minus x squared over two sigma
squared, a rescaling?
But this would be the
bell-shaped curve.
The bell-shaped curve.
It decays very quickly.
The variance, because
that's a two and not
a two sigma squared, the
standard deviation is one here.
The variance is one.
So it's a bell shaped
curve that has about 2/3
of its area between
minus one and one.
This is the all important
function for probability.
The normal distribution, the
Gaussian, both of those words
are used, it's the most
important probability
distribution.
I need a one over
square root of 2pi
to make the total
probability be one.
But let me just leave it there.
That's a very, very
important function.
It's also going to be
important in the heat equation.
In math finance, shows
up all over the place.
And its integral would not be
easy to do from zero to one.
The integral of that
function, from zero to one,
we have tables of it.
To the nth place.
But so there's no simple,
elementary function
whose derivative is this.
That x squared is what's
making the integral tricky.
So from zero to one, we
just have to give it a name.
So, error function.
This would be E-R-F,
error function,
the integral of that thing
correctly normalized.
I'm just saying, important,
important function.
And it turns out that integrals
from minus infinity to infinity
can be done.
So, beautifully,
by some trickery,
we can find the
transform of this.
We can find the
transform of this,
we can do this integral from
minus infinity to infinity,
where we could not do
it from zero to one.
So I'll just write down
the answer for this guy.
Only because it's
such a key example.
It's some constant that
involves 2pi times e
to the minus k squared over two.
Boy, that's pretty amazing.
Right, the Fourier integral
transform, f hat of k,
has the same form
as the function.
And of course this function
is infinitely smooth.
So its transform
decays infinitely fast.
Yeah, there's no problems
like one over k squared here,
there are no bumps in
the bell shaped curve.
So I won't push that
example except I'll use it.
What else should I
say just to, like,
emphasize that this is such
an important distribution
in probability?
Why is it important
That's the question.
Why does everybody assume,
if you can get away with it
and don't have any natural
alternative, everybody
assumes that noise,
whatever, is coming
with a normal distribution.
So, in other words, with
a sigma squared in there.
So a normal distribution,
that has mean
zero because it's absolutely
centered at the origin
and it has variance one, but
I could change the variance
and that would just
spread out or tighten
the bell-shaped curve.
Why is the bell-shaped
curve so important?
That's certainly,
we're not going
to launch into
theory of probability
but it's the central
limit theorem.
So let me just use those words.
The central limit
theorem that says
that if I start with other
probability distributions,
like I'm flipping a coin.
I flip a coin a million times.
Then the mean, and let's say
zero for tails, one for heads.
OK, so I flip, flip, flip.
Well, the mean of
that, the expected mean
is what, half a million, right?
Half tails, half heads.
So if I give zero for
tails, one for heads
and flip a million
times the mean
would be about half a million.
And then, so let
me center the mean.
I could have centered it by
taking minus one and one.
That would have been smarter.
Minus one and one.
Minus one for
tails, one for heads
would have had a mean of zero.
And then it would be
natural if I have a million
of these to divide by
a thousand, I think.
Of course, the answer
won't be zero, right?
If I do a million
flips it's not going
to come out exactly half a
million and half a million.
I'm remembering.
I used to have a long discussion
with a nice guy in college.
He ran for Mayor of
Boston, actually.
But he had the idea that
after a million flips,
suppose there had been
more heads than tails.
Then the next flip, he figured,
was more likely to be tails.
I couldn't convince them that
this was not mathematically
the right thing to think about.
And all I did was say
don't go to Las Vegas.
I mean, if you're thinking
that way, save your money.
So, anyway.
But this is much studied.
The variation, what
that curve looks like,
that's quite interesting.
But my point is, that as the
number gets bigger and bigger
and we scale it properly,
the distribution
will approach the normal.
All sorts of distributions.
If I just repeat and repeat
experiments and scale it,
the central limit theorem
says you're always going
to the normal distribution.
So that's highly important.
OK, and it comes up
different places.
And it's quite a neat function.
OK, so that's some examples.
Now, let me use, like every
topics that I introduce,
I want to find a use for.
So now, can I start on this one?
Constant coefficient
differential equations.
I'm going to write down a
differential equation, which
will look pretty
much like the ones we
started this course with.
And I could, well,
let me write it down.
Minus d second u dx
squared, we're used to that.
Now let me put in
an a squared u.
Which is a lower lower order
term, we could deal with that.
Equals some f(x).
And now, because I want
to do Fourier integrals,
I'm thinking all x.
We're on the whole line.
Instead of the
interval (0,1) where
I might use Fourier
series and have
sine series or cosine series,
depending on the boundary
conditions.
Here, the boundary condition
is just everything drops off
at infinity.
And minus infinity.
So all these functions,
we can do these integrals.
OK, so there's a good question.
What's the solution?
We could tackle it, but I want
to suggest to use Fourier.
So it's not the only way,
but it's one way to see it.
So now if I use, what do
I mean by using Fourier?
It means I'm going to take
the Fourier integral transform
of every term.
So when I take the
Fourier transform
of the right-hand side, I'm
going to get f hat of k,
whatever.
This is known, of course.
This guy is given.
That's the source term.
And u is the unknown.
OK, so I'm going
to take the Fourier
transform of every term, well
this is, a is a constant. a
had to be a constant,
or I couldn't do,
you know if a depended
on x this would
be some multiplication and
the transform would be a mess.
Fourier applies when you've
got constant coefficients
and nice boundary conditions.
And here our boundary
conditions are nice,
they just go to zero fast.
OK, so the transform of this is,
that's a constant. u hat of k.
And what's the
transform of that?
So this is our chance
to use probably
the most important rule
for Fourier integrals.
Maybe you'll tell me what it is.
You should think what it is.
If I take a derivative,
that's the rule.
If I take a derivative
of the function,
what's happening in frequencies?
I could make that happen here.
If I took the derivative, yeah.
So maybe if I take
the derivative here,
so here it's just
remembering the rule.
Suppose I take the
derivative of this equation.
I get this integral,
and what would f' be?
What would f hat, sorry.
If I take the x
derivative of this,
if I take the x derivative
of this equation,
what happens on
the right-hand side
when I take the x derivative?
Down comes ik.
So when ik is coming
down, I won't even
finish that equation.
And ik is coming down,
when I take the derivative.
So the derivative, the
transform, is multiplied by ik,
higher frequencies
are emphasized now
because of that k factor.
And now if I take two
derivatives, I bring ik twice.
So that's i squared k
squared, the i squared
and the minus give me a plus.
So that's just k
squared. u hat, of k.
OK with that?
And now, we get an
immediate formula
for u hat of k, the solution.
Well, it's the solution but
it's in frequency space.
If we wanted to know it
in x space, as we do,
we've got to transform back.
But what do we get here?
It's just f hat of k.
Divided by, this is just
multiplied by a squared plus k
squared.
OK, so that's the answer.
In frequency space.
That was simple.
And then if I wanted
it in x space,
I take the reverse transform.
Notice that this is, hidden
here are the same three steps
that I emphasize all the
time about using eigenvectors
and eigenvalues.
Do you remember
those three steps
for solving
differential equations?
Difference equations,
linear equations, whatever?
The three steps were,
find the coefficients,
expand everything
in eigenfunctions.
I won't write, I'll talk.
The three steps were
expand in eigenfunctions,
follow each eigenfunction
function separately,
that was the trivial step
with just a division,
like this division.
And then use those coefficients
of the eigenfunctions,
combine them all back
to get the answer.
Right?
Step one: write it in the
right basis, step two:
easy in that basis.
Step three: go back to
your physical space.
We're doing exactly
the same thing here.
These e^(ikx)'s are the
eigenfunctions of this thing.
They're the eigenfunctions.
And here the eigenvalue
of this stuff
is k squared plus a squared.
And that's what we divided by.
And then the final job
of going back from u hat
to u, by-- So write u there.
Can I do, this f,
now it's really u
that I'm wanting to bring
back to physical space.
So just for the sake
of your eyes seeing it,
let me put a u in.
So that's the answer in a way.
It's the answer, it's a
formula for the answer.
It did depend on our being
able to do two integrals.
The integral from f to f
hat may not have been easy,
and then the integral from u
hat back to u, this integral,
might not have been easy.
So it's a formula.
OK, now I want to go
with it a little longer.
Because I want to show you how
the delta function pays off.
So let me do the example where
f(x) is the delta function.
So now we're really close
to where this course began.
Differential equation
with a delta function.
The only new thing is,
we're not on an interval,
we're on the whole line.
So I take transforms, so
what's the transform now
of this specific f(x) is?
One.
We just saw.
OK, so now we get a one there.
Now we just divide by here.
And we've got a one here.
So we were able to go,
this was an integral
we could easily do, to get
from delta to delta hat, which
was just one.
And fantastically, this is an
integral to go back to u(x),
to go back to u(x), that's
an integral we can do.
Well, you may ask
how can we do it.
How do I find the u(x)
that has this transform?
Well, I either use complex
variables to do integrals
like this, residue methods
that are in Chapter 5,
or I look in a table.
Or I look at the
blackboard over there.
I think that's the best way.
Look at this blackboard.
Right?
Because this is
the answer we got.
We got that same answer apart
from a constant factor 2a.
So this is our function.
This is our solution,
u(x) is this.
What am I going to call that?
Two-sided pulse?
I'll call that the
two-sided pulse?
Maybe I should give it a
name but I'll just write out
those words two-sided pulse.
That's it, divided by 2a.
So we've got the answer.
Let me just make a
little more space here.
This was one over a
squared plus k squared,
and now having seen that
already, I just say yep,
that must be it.
It's the two-sided pulse,
and I have to divide by 2a.
Do you see that that's
the correct answer?
We can substitute that in the
equation and see that it works.
I mean, so we have
solved the problem.
We have solved the problem
when the right side was delta.
Let's put it into the equation.
So this is just
because we did this,
it's nice to do it again
after all this time.
So I put it in the equation.
This two-sided pulse over 2a.
So what's my equation?
Well, this is zero
most of the time.
So I believe that if I
plug in this function,
it will give me the zero.
Do you want to just plug it in?
I believe that if I plug in
a^(-x), or a^x, either one,
can I just check that
u-- Try u=e^(-ax).
Put it in and just
see that I get zero.
Because yeah, two
derivatives bring down
a squared with a minus.
And there's a
squared with a plus.
It works, right?
Two derivatives of this function
bring down minus a twice,
so that's a squared.
So it's minus a
squared, plus a squared.
Works.
And then, of course, the
important point is x=0 where
the spike is.
What happens at the
spike, going back
to the beginning of the course?
This term is going
to be unimportant
compared to this term.
What do I see?
With -u'' equal a spike, what
was the solution to that?
u had a corner, right?
The slope of u, what
did the slope of u do?
It dropped by one,
was that right?
The slope of u dropped by one.
We used to have corners
going up and down
and the difference between
the slopes was one.
And here, the difference
between the slopes, ah, look.
The slope has dropped by 2a,
and when we divided by the 2a,
it was just right.
And now, when I divide by the
2a, this has a slope of 1/2.
This has a slope of minus
1/2, the drop is one.
And we're right.
It solves the equation.
Nobody doubted that.
OK, so that's great.
We have found the
solution to this equation,
when the right side is delta.
Good.
Now, can I ask you do
you remember the name?
There's a special name for the
solution when the right side is
a delta function.
Whose name is
associated with that?
So that this
particular u, I'm going
to give it another letter.
It's the particular
u, the special u
when the right side is
delta, and whose name is
associated with that solution?
Green.
It's the Green's function.
Green's function.
The famous Green's function.
Green's function is just like
an inverse to the problem.
This is like having an identity
on the right-hand side.
It's like there it is.
So let me just use G
for Green's function.
So that's the Fourier transform
of the Green's function,
and this is the
Green's function.
This is the Green's function.
Now I can give it its
name, Green's function,
when I divide by the 2a.
And now the slope is 1/2 going
up, and minus 1/2 coming down.
And it's all right.
OK, so we found the
Green's function.
We found the fundamental
solution to the equation,
and this is it.
It was straight lines, right?
It was straight lines in the
first weeks of the course.
But now there's an
exponential drop-off
caused by this additional term.
OK, good.
So that's straightforward.
Depending on our being
able to recognize or do
the transform back
to the x space.
Now comes the question, what
about the original f(x)?
How can the Green's
function be used?
So you're seeing now, what
use is this Green's function?
With that right-hand side,
when the right-hand side
is something different?
When the right-hand side
is some different f(x)?
So let me go back to
an f(x) on the right.
And then there's an f hat
of k, after the transform.
How can I use the Green's
function for a general source?
The general source
term, a general load?
This is a fundamental idea.
I would say fundamental.
How do you use the
Green's function?
And remember, the
Green's function
is like telling you
the inverse matrix.
So it can't be too hard.
It's like solving a
linear system when
you know the inverse matrix.
So that's the analogy,
but let's just focus
on the particular question.
I think the
intuition, you should
have an intuition for how
the Green's function works.
So the Green's function
was the solution when
the source term was a delta.
And here's the intuition.
It's rough, but it works.
Any source term,
f(x), is in some way
a combination of delta.
If f(x) is a
combination of deltas,
then our answer u(x)
is the same combination
of the Green's function, right?
If the right-hand side
is some combination
of this special delta, then
the solution will be the same.
This is just linearity.
Superposition, whatever short
or long word you like to use.
So if I can make sense
of that statement,
that f(x) is a combination
of deltas, then I'm in.
Now, what do I mean by
a combination of deltas?
I mean, well, those deltas are
going to be shifted deltas.
Obviously the single
delta, delta(x),
is a spike at the origin.
That's only one point.
I want to combine delta
of x and its shifts.
So I'm going to have
to expect to be using
G(x) and its shifts, right?
OK so now I'll just
say this again.
I'm thinking of f(x) as
a combination of delta
and its shifts, and
then the solution u
will be the same combination
of G(x) and its shifts.
So now you just have to
tell me what combination.
What combination of
delta and its shifts?
Maybe you'll allow me.
Let me just do this
maybe on that board.
I just can't help writing
down the discrete case.
So, in the discrete
case, the delta vector
corresponds to something
like [1, 0, 0, 0].
Right?
That was a typical
delta vector with a one
in the zeroth position.
Then its shifts would be [0, 1,
0, 0], that'd be a shift.
And another shift
would be [0,  0, 1, 0].
would be [0,  0, 0, 1].
So now there is the delta
vector and its shifts.
These four guys.
OK, now suppose my f,
my right-hand side,
is [1, 2, 3, 7].
I want to write that as a
combination of those deltas.
This would be in the case when
if I know the solution for each
of these guys, the Green's
function, the inverse matrix.
Everybody sees if I know
the solution to those four,
I know the inverse matrix.
Right?
Because if I can solve with
those four right-hand sides,
those four solutions are the
columns of the inverse matrix.
Right?
You remember that
if I had a matrix A
and I was looking
for its inverse,
I solve A A inverse equal I.
And I is just these four guys.
So A inverse is the solution
from these four guys.
OK, now everybody's
going to tell me
what's the solution for this
right-hand side [1, 2, 3, 7]?
Suppose this guy has
solution, so A inverse,
the columns of A inverse
are this Green's function.
This Green's function
with a shift.
Maybe SG, Green's
function with a shift.
Yeah, S squared G, Green's
function with a double shift.
S cubed G. I'm just
cooking up, I never
used these letters before.
But what's the answer?
Then u is what?
It's one times the
Green's function.
And it's two times
the guy, right?
This f is just,
this f is just, is
one times the Green's function,
two times the shifted.
Three times the double
shifted, and seven times
the triple shift.
Right?
Just taking four minutes to
do something simple because
over there, when I use
the continuous case
it'll look a little strange,
but here it's so easy.
That'll involve integrals,
this involves a sum.
So what is it?
I have G, twice the
shift of G. Three
times the double shift of G,
and seven times the triple shift
of G. Right?
By linearity, by superposition,
if this is my f, this is my u.
Everybody's with me here, right?
That if I take a combination
of f's, the answer is
the corresponding
combination of G's.
OK, good.
I didn't mean that.
That wasn't so great.
That shouldn't
have been called, I
didn't mean to call those
the Green's functions.
I meant to call those
the deltas, right?
And the Green's functions
were the answers.
So this a shifted delta, this
is a doubly shifted delta,
this is a triply
shifted delta, and now
this is one of the delta, two
of the shifted delta, three
of the doubly shifted delta.
The f is a combination
of deltas and its shifts.
The u is a combination
of Green's function,
and its shifts.
Apologies for
making that mistake,
but maybe it's brought
us back to the point.
So the point is, express
your function f, your source,
as a combination of deltas,
just exactly our plan.
Then u is the same combination
of the G's with the same shift.
Alright, now back here.
How do I express
f(x), in what way is
f(x) a combination of deltas?
I mean, slow down just
to see that point.
How much of delta, of the spike
at x=3, how much of delta(x-3),
so that's a spike
at three, right?
How much of that do you
think I need in f(x)? f of?
f(3).
Whatever f is at
that point, x=3,
that's the amount I need there.
So this would be f(3).
So that that part
would sort of have
the right pep, the right
punch, at the point three.
Now, three could be
any point, that's
any point along the line.
Let me, I can't use x for
other points on the line
because I've got an
x in the formula.
Let me use t.
So this was t equal to three.
Now I want to do
it at all points.
I want to take f(2), and
f(pi), and f at everything
and put them together.
And of course putting them
together in the continuous case
means not sum, as I did
there, but integrate.
So I have to, now I'm going
to change three to a t,
because this is
the amount of f of,
so that's the amount, that's
the delta functions which spike
at t, multiplied by
f(t), and now how
do I get f(x) out of this?
I put them together. dt.
I add up, this is
the combination
I've been talking about.
So this is like any f.
This is like a crazy
delta function identity.
Actually, it's not
crazy, it's the identity
we've used our whole lives.
Or at least our whole
18.085 lives, which
is all that matters, right?
OK, so I'm integrating
a delta function.
And I want to see,
do I get that answer?
And you're going to say
absolutely, clearly you
get that answer.
No.
Everybody knows that if I
integrate something times
a delta function that I
plug in at the point t=x,
where that spike happens, I
put t=x, I get f(x), correct.
So that's like any,
that's an identity
or whatever you would
like to call it.
And now just tell
me the final answer.
Let me put it on
the board above.
Now, so this was,
this expressed my f(x)
as a combination of deltas.
Just the way over here
I expressed [1, 2, 3, 7]
as a combination of deltas.
Now, what's that u?
What's the function u?
The solution that
comes from f(x).
Just erase here so that
I can put all of them.
The point of the
whole example now
is for you to tell
me what's u(x)?
Can you do it?
You see what u(x) is
going to come out?
It's going to come out nicely.
I've written the right-hand side
f as a combination of deltas.
I know the answer, for delta.
It's G. What's the answer when
the delta is shifted along?
What's the Green's function
when the spike is moved along
to a point t?
Just, because this
constant-coefficient,
translation-invariant, LTI
problem is shift invariant,
the answer, when the
spike is moved along,
is just the answer
G moved along.
So here's my answer.
All this, this is my input and
my output is the same integral,
this from minus infinity to
infinity, of -- where it was f,
now it's G. Well
no, what do I want?
Help me out here.
No, f(t) is just the
amount of the delta,
but now what's the solution?
What do I write now?
G of?
x-t.
That's it.
You see why that works?
Because this was the
input, G's the output.
The problem was shift invariant,
so if I shifted the input
I shifted the output.
It was linear, so if I
add up a bunch of deltas,
the solution is add up a
bunch of G. That's the answer.
Oh, I could just
say one thing more.
But you've got it
if you see math.
So that's the point, that if
you know the Green's function,
well yeah.
Maybe from a practical point
of view, what have we done?
The original way we did
it involved our computing
two integrals.
We had to, if we were
given an f(x), we
had to find its
transform f hat of k,
that we weren't sure we could
do with pencil and paper.
And then we got an answer
with an f hat of k up here
and then we had
to transform back.
Step one and step
three, we had to do.
Now this is better.
This is like better,
because we were
able to get an explicit answer,
G, when this was a delta.
You could say I've got
it down to one integral.
Well, for whatever that's worth.
I was going to say,
probably can't do that one
either depending what f(x) is.
But that's a nice way to see
the answer, you have to admit.
And it's because the
problem is shift-invariant
and I can write the
answer that way.
OK, and now one more
thing about this.
And I've written the word,
the key word, down here.
Convolution.
Do you see the nice way
to write that answer?
It's the convolution
of f with G.
We didn't do integral
convolutions,
we just did the discrete
sums, but I mentioned
that in the integral case,
you have this same thing. t
and x-t adding up
to x, just the way
we had k and n-k adding up to n.
In other words, this
is just notation.
But I'm just going to write
the answer in a nice way.
So after all that
lecture, the answer
to the differential equations
is in three symbols f star G.
Where this just
simply means this.
This is the continuous
convolution, not cyclic,
and there's the answer.
I'll allow myself
one more thing.
Here we had a convolution
for the right-hand side.
We started with this,
this is a convolution.
Now, what are the three
symbols that I write down?
For the shorthand
for this equation?
So this was to be
true for any f.
And now can I write
down, how do I write?
f(x) is equal to, what
is this right-hand side?
It's f convolved with?
So any f is the same f
convolved with delta.
In convolution, delta is one.
Because when I go
to the other space
and I get a multiplication,
it really is one, right?
In the other space.
So in the other space, so
this convolution in x space
turns into multiplication
in frequency space.
And it just tells me that
f hat is f hat times one.
So that's the way to look
at it in physical space.
And this is the way to
look at the solution.
So, one more thought and
I'll come back to that.
So this G, the
Green's function, this
is what a CAT scan does,
what an X-ray telescope does.
What all sorts of
physical things do.
Provided we can assume this
translation invariance,
which is never perfectly
true because the telescope is
finite.
But a telescope takes the
star, takes the light signal,
convolves it with the
telescope's own little Green's
function.
It blurs it, it's the
point spread function.
It's the blurring function,
G. The Green's function
on a telescope is
somehow, that's what's
you're convolving with.
And if you want to find that
star as a bright, single point.
You've got to do deconvolution.
You've got to do a
division to get the G out.
May I just say those words
and then it's Thanksgiving?
That a machine, a sensor which
is translation invariant,
or you could say close
enough to pretend it is,
because nothing is going
to be perfectly translation
invariant all the
way out to infinity.
But if it's near the star.
So I look at this point star
in the telescope I see a blur.
That's because the telescope
has convolved the correct thing,
that I should have seen,
with G. It's blurred it
by its point spread function.
So what if the
person, the factory
where the telescope was built
can test this whole thing
on points.
And it can find the
point spread function.
And if I knew G,
then I could undo it.
And get a clear picture.
So it's that step that won the
Nobel Prize for the CAT scan,
and I'm sure is winning
Nobel Prizes for astronomers.
OK, have a great Thanksgiving,
I'll see you Monday.
Good.